how are you doing today good how are you
i'm doing good i like your t-shirt thank
you
vintage
hey you can't go wrong with guns and
roses
yeah nirvana guns and roses those are my
like to go go to like vintage tees if i
could find them
um also uh both of them have incredible
first albums yes
seriously uh okay we're jumping into why
i get to talk to you um what is the
secret to playing a badass hacker
uh well faking it because i'm not a
hacker whatsoever i'm not good at
technology i don't know any i you know i
had to i actually watched
some movies to be quite honest with you
like i watched the matrix before i was
just trying to get a vibe my brother is
actually
quite incredible at like he built his
own his own computer from like
scratch like each piece when he was like
12. like he's amazing at that stuff so
um um i was i had to fake it i don't but
i had to kind of no act like i knew what
what was happening
so but i mean you
i i would have i would imagine it's all
about the clothing and the attitude
absolutely
you know it's like just just the
attitude but so when you walk on set and
you see the rig that they're portraying
that you're going to be controlling are
you sort of just like
you know what i mean yeah cause like i
was playing around with the computers
and i was like what does this do what
does that do and it did absolutely
nothing and then they were like no we're
gonna have to cue it so i was just like
i was having the time of my life i felt
like i was like in the matrix or
something it was so fun but i think once
i put the wig on
you know like that cool i had like i had
a cool like black wig that was kind of
super edgy and that put me in a
different space and then like the matrix
you know like the the pleather pants and
the black all the black it was cool it
was cool it was fun
was this because i believe this is your
first like movie um was this something
that you've been looking to do how did
this actually like land in your lap
i've gone like i've my agent have sent
me a lot of scripts um i have a really
hard time like i
if i don't love something i can't finish
it like i've tried reading some scripts
i've gotten in like 10 pages and then
i'm like i can't do this um but with
this script i started reading it and i
actually like i couldn't stop reading i
was like wow this is a really good
script and then um yeah i just got
through to the end like i i don't know
how but i did and um i just loved what i
loved how it was like instead of
kingpins it was a flip on the queen pins
and it was about two you know normal
girls women who become like who make
this make tons of money and are like
these badass girls because always the
guys who do it
and um
i thought it would be cool it just felt
right i just
my theory is like if it feels good and
it feels right in my gut why not just
try it it doesn't hurt sure you know
what i mean also
100 also i think there's just some
element of with the coupons that
everyone can relate to that like you
know like no matter
everyone relates to coupons everybody
loves coupons i don't care who you are i
mean i don't know maybe some people but
like when you go to the store and you
get two dollars off on like
carton of milk or whatever it's awesome
like it's exciting
yeah listen everyone loves coupon but so
i'm curious this is your first movie
what really surprised you about the
process of making a movie like this that
maybe you weren't expecting going in
um i you know what it what surprised me
is it very similar like to cutting a
song and singing a song in the studio
because in the studio you know you're
you're basically like essentially like
singing apart like you know let's say
you're singing the hook you're singing
the hook through and it depends on like
how you like to sing but like um
like you could sing the song through
let's say from the top to the bottom
just to get a vibe right and you could
sing it five six times and then you will
go and comp what the best parts are
maybe you said it differently here you
said the word differently here with
acting i had no idea i thought it was
like i don't know i didn't know what to
expect but you know you have the
director there
and the other you know actors and
actresses who are supporting you and
it's just about saying things in a
different way and
you know what i learned is like acting
is
it's quite hard you know it's not easy
because it's like about intentions and
where you stop and how you say things
and
but it's similar to music so i mean
but and also in the sense of cutting a
song and the way they you know cut and
edit the movie
but then also what i really loved about
it a good thing that i really loved was
the um
everybody on set was just so nice
you know
there was like no stress everybody was
just like this is like work like you
know they've been doing this for weeks
now
it's just like a cool energy
music video it's like
10 seconds change over we have to we're
going to go into overtime and it's like
not it's just like
so much
stress in a music video
i think with music i gotta go but i
think with music videos um you sometimes
only have one day to shoot everything
and with a movie you have a lot more
time it's so much more fun and also the
budget for food is so much bigger so
it's like much better
crafty uh hey listen thank you so much
for your time and congrats on being part
of the movie thank you